my bad I
uh I messed it up
slightly hit reboot without
realizing subcription service agreement
works this is the setting that gets
everyone
confused this is not a restart full
machine I hope it should just be restart
Docker desktop
is that's how easy it is to set up
puffer tank brand new machine
download I don't know why my chat's not
working I don't think I can see anything
[Music]
here hold on maybe I'll just bring it up
on I think I can get it on restream
right
stream okay so I'll have to fix some
stuff
but hopefully chat is chat is good audio
should be
working I'm going to have to do some
maintenance
hey YouTube folks real stream later this
afternoon lots of cool Dev I'm just
getting stuff set up but this is kind of
good for people to see how easy it is to
just set up a new box with all the RL
stuff from scratch I mean this is
literally it you just get popper tank
and you're good to
go so that's
website and I need to install a few
other things as well right while I'm
check your
email
go full puffer
setup breakout in five
minutes there's this one drop
here that's solid
this is almost done so hopefully we get
this container up and running we run a
couple basic tests and then I will head
to the gym and then I'll be back in the
not as good as it should
be uploads
I really just want to have this thing
set up oh I should get tail scale as
well while I'm at
it I think could do that on my other
account oops
this is what we use for
servers makes things
IPS that shouldn't really matter with
tail scale but
still I think I still have to download
it locally right
there it
is so in a second this will
connect and now it's
connected and then we
brand new machine took 30 seconds to get
tail scale and set up an SSH you just
have direct SSH access you
know and see I have a job running on
here nice and
snappy and now here this one took a
little longer to
download um but now we can see that
we're in this
container and I can see I have my local
machine
which has is an AMD
machine going to be
different let's see if this actually
this might work
uh Das do
[Music]
oh we need to check the config actually
cuz this is not optimized for
um I have a few things to set up here
all right
so I'm not used to the uh the position
position of the uh the arrows on this
keyboard yet this new
this this is just me not being used to
the position of the arrow keys
just basic workstation
setup I mean I would say this is really
not that bad though
considering companies have like multiple
day setup on a machine that they give
you this is just like a brand new
machine with just Windows on it and it's
taking me
like maybe an hour to get all my normal
stuff including the full RL
stack I'm seeing comments now let's see
can you suggest me some
Niche deep learning RL folks on Twitch
there are not that many people doing RL
on Twitch my friend um that would
basically just be me hey
Ryan but I will be on here a lot um the
intented that I will be
streaming probably at least 5 hours of
Dev per day throughout the week probably
more I was pretty consistent with that
before I went to Florida and I didn't
have a desktop and then that just took
way longer to show up than it was
supposed to
so now we have a really nice set
up I still have to get used to this
keyboard
I don't
like I guess it's
okay I'll show you this it feels really
good to type on it's just the num the uh
the arrow keys are positioned a little
weird I don't know if I can pull this
back for enough so this
is new razor black widow
V4 uh it actually does I will give them
credit this actually feels like a pretty
nice upgrade over my previous V3
it's got like a nice metal body it's got
a way better wrist
rest all the RL folks are on Twitch or
blue sky nope I'm still on
X the going to Blue Sky thing is really
dumb like you're just going to get one
of your
here is our
tari now we only have 16 cores but they
should be faster so we're going to try
an M bat size of
32 as our
initial initial thing and then what was
this one this is times three so I think
this is
96 is what we
want yeah
what I do
wrong have you consider doing
both posting if I could do it automated
like
maybe um but the thing is like social
media is kind of just cancer so I'd like
to not spend more time on apps
what I do wrong
here share big post possibly
I mean like the reason that like that
that app even exists is people bitching
about X for stupid reasons so
like I don't get the
point they're just doing better because
like PE currently people are really
pissed about X I guess that's the only
reason they're even doing anything it's
not like they built a better platform or
they built anything remotely
interesting um something is wrong here
I'm trying to
remember what this
is since the election I get
90% so I went to
xhq relatively
recently um
from what I can tell the algorithm is
just very
sensitive I did a little experiment
where if you just like or just not
interested in every single post for 100
posts you basically clean up your whole
feed it's really easy to just fix your
where is this bug
650 this is not a bug with puffer I just
forget how this works I should make a
note to fix
this I'm just really not used to like I
got to figure out with what's up with
the keyboard I think like the arrows are
in just a weird
spot yeah the arrows are just like
slightly off of where I expect them to
be so it's kind of awkward until I get
used to
can you let stay let your VOD stay
online so twitch doesn't let you um if
you're not affiliated but they're online
permanently with YouTube so if you just
go check the I'm on the neural MMO
YouTube you have all of my Dev vods from
forever
here you see like there's something
weird where I keep you see I like keep
hitting the quote key I think I just
have to get used to it but I do want to
take a look at the it feels really good
to type on to be fair it's just like I
can tell there are a couple keys that
are not where I'm used to them
being the switches feel really good on
this though
spinning up list the spinning up list
has way too many papers Ryan I put a
shorter list it's actually it's on see
this is why X is useful I can put
articles on it
here I have a full quick start guide
that has papers and stuff as
well yeah getting started post this is
this one did pretty well
Uh something's weird
here 1%
n wait what
1%
what's wrong with the GPU right
now and B
size set this to
64 like what's wrong with
this see you
Ryan yeah I'm going to the gym and if
you as well and then I'll be back for an
afternoon
stream send that to M100 oh yeah yeah
yeah I forgot
oh is it just because I'm
streaming it could literally just be
because I'm
streaming yeah you can see it's okay so
it's just because I'm
streaming okay so I know what we can
I don't have an idle box to test but I'm
pretty sure that you get
60k with
um I'm pretty sure that you get
60k with the Intel
[Music]
H I'm also running a bunch of stuff to
be fair though so I'm going to want to
run this again when I'm not
streaming and I'm going to do a few
other things as well they're going to
definitely be some tests I'm going to
have to do
here vanilla x what the hell
I had vanilla as a keyword in one of my
posts and I have an ad from a vanilla
company yeah
okay all right so I we got this stuff
set up um I'm in a good spot I can start
doing some proper Dev uh as soon as I
get back from gym and I'm going to run
these results as soon as I shut the
stream off and we're going to see how
that goes and we'll go from there uh
proper Dev in probably about 3ish
hours ha list M yeah well I'll be back
with the real Dev this was just a quick
test stream to set some stuff up I'll be
back uh back for real and